well I would say the fundamental thing
for me that is at stake is our ability
to say what we want to
say I mean it's really really basic um
that increasingly the view is that there
are certain things that should not be
said because they are problematic or
offensive for The Listener MH um and I'm
not going to say it's a move from
objectivism to subjectivism because the
speaker also has a subject point of view
but it's a move
from uh a subjectivism that gives
privileges to someone of a positive sort
namely expression and instead seeds the
privilege to a different kind of
subjectivity which is that that can shut
things down um and for me those are
really really high stakes I think it's a
wonderful point but I I I do think I
said in the beginning you know we are in
living in an expanding world so you know
uh we saw in this morning's discussion
we have art history you talk about
Western Civilization but there are many
other uh histories there are many
different perspectives and clearly and
also in the academic world not all of
them have been heard before and H and so
there are there are levels of inequality
so the question is how can we indeed
expand without you know shutting voices
down because I think it's all about
hearing more voices uh having a wider
discussion have a so to say more
diversity in our our in our discussions
U with all but I think we should also be
cognant of the emotions of those who
were not heard before so there's this
very delicate balance I think that you
have to strike where you you know this
this funny way where you have to be
really tolerant but know do you want to
be tolerant of intolerant probably not
and I think that's where it becomes
tricky so I I agree completely with both
of you but I I think something strange
has happened and it's to do with the way
in which um media and movements travel
and America has a very very important
voice particularly in the Anglo world
and all this and in a sense I feel I
don't feel when I'm talking to students
that I'm being shut up um when I say
something which might come from a prior
generation uh iranic aign called free
expression is no offense when I was
president of Penn so I know about all
these insult and Salon Roy and all the
other phenomena but I think what's
happened now is that the culture wars
and and the people who are doing the
shutting up are not only the new
Puritans but they are the far right and
they have co-opted what in in some
instances are are you know people who
really don't have a say and who should
have a say into um being the uh
opposition to free expression whereas in
fact it is the far right uh the altright
who are the opposers of free expression
and only want the kind of expression
that's owned by very rich media to be
theirs and you know I I think we have to
play this carefully I I don't think it's
a you know it's culture wars between two
sides I think there's a side with a lot
of power and then there are many other
small others I'd like to jump on in on
the
[Music]
uh I heard this morning and at the
beginning of this conversation uh and in
fact in the essay uh a kind of a binary
argument you're with tradition or you're
not it's one
tradition uh and I think what we're all
seeing here also is not only there are
more of those Traditions there are more
points of view uh but we in the cultural
sector are in a very I think in a very
important position to embrace the gray
area in between these to and what's
happening is we're seeing the gray area
shrinking and that platform is less and
less available to people while that is
so incredibly important to find some way
to recognize these different traditions
and to find a way to learn from them and
to expand our minds and I think that's
maybe the most worrying thing to me
anyway and that's why it's important to
actually lie this forces with the force
of the puritanical far right but I must
say that if you have this point of inde
you know widening and having more
perspective it's not necessarily be will
be very comfortable and I would even add
to it you know it it really undermines
the central premise of education is that
you're being shaped by ideas opinions
that are new they might be uncomfortable
so it's not that everything you learn
about the world makes you feel
comfortable but I typically feel like
for instance University should be in
some sense the most uncomfortable place
because that's where young minds are
shaped and I feel there's a certain
tendency you know sometimes parents of
young children they tape uh foam in on
all the corners of the table so that
their children won't bump their hats and
I think that's definitely not what a
university should be for you the
cultural war is a fiction you don't
know how it's
going in the daily life I know yep I
know I came from a country
which is where is uh the
freedom and the free
speech and to
articulating your
interests and the whole society is
frozen M and I know what this means how
killing the souls
how the people
are maybe you know
to uh you know how the people are they
don't have courage
anymore they it's a
nightmare and I so for you it's a
fiction
but to do to do and to show
up and the way of the
resistance you know it's getting more
and more difficult
and of course you don't have any other
chance just
resist but the other
hand you know you pay a horrible
price